now this is these are geometry questions
all of them okay and do you remember the
probability questions have been looking
at over the past few days which also had
you interview them I always said the
very first step you should do before you
even write anything for a geometry
question you should always you should
always draw it right now these questions
something maybe you don't need to draw
them but if you don't know what to do
you're like I'm not sure or you're not
you haven't answer but you're not sure
if that's right
it will help don't really help okay so
let's have a look at this a square is 9
centimeters long so join us off the
square squares 9 seventies long there
you go ok now what's the question they
asked for the ratio of now stops do
remember when we're looking at the
probability questions before as soon as
I as I read the word I hear the word
probability I say probability equals and
then I read a fraction right and you
remember what was on the top and what
was on the bottom okay yeah this is very
similar just a little different if you
can think back to fractions and
percentages and ratios ratios are
written in a certain way they're written
as some number to some other number okay
so this is the way I mean the most
frequent place might hear about this in
real life is like on when you do bets
okay so we'd say are the odds are two to
one
well what did 27 or whatever okay that's
a ratio okay so that call that means you
read that is 2 okay so once you've got
the ratio just like what's your
probability you just need to know what
these two pieces are okay and the
question tells you it says what's the
ratio of the length length to the
perimeter
okay so now I just need to know what
these two pieces are and I'll have my
ratio okay now they told you already
what the length is what's the length
okay now primitive how do we work our
pruder again it's it's going all the way
around I've got to add all of these
lengths right all the way around prove
it it goes all the way around okay as if
we took a piece of string and then
stretched it around that shape so it's
going to be 36 it's going to be nine
plus nine equals nine across my
four-times line 36 now that's the first
part
do you remember well we have like a
fraction we work in a probability you
might get say you know the total events
you're interested in is you know three
out of the sample space is six you write
that down that's a fraction but we're
not finished at this point are we what
could we do I can simplify the cancer
that notice what would you do in this
case now you could take out a factor of
three on the top of the bottom you could
do exactly the same thing here what's
the common factor I could take out its
nine isn't it it's nice and you can sort
of see that because we got 36 by saying
for times like so yeah it's a it's not 1
over 4 that's a fraction
yeah it's 1 2 4 okay now just before we
finish and leave this question I've
quickly to ask you write ratios the
automat is right 1 2 4 is not the same
as 4 to 1 like if you were doing a bet
right one of these is a good bet one's a
really bad one okay so the question for
you is which one of these is the
question interest to do is it the red
one or the green one and have you tell
who records it's the red one we've got a
few heads okay you know I think it's the
green one and someone who you're
confused or non-committal that's fine
okay it is the red one most you guys
right now here's the way we can tell
okay good actually regional question it
says leg two perimeter right so one of
these will be a smaller number one will
be bigger so you think about which one's
bigger which one's small
yeah you should always simplify oh just
like you'd always simplify probability
you should always simplify ratio okay